people living at an apartment complex in
the downtown las vegas area say the
stairs
still missing at their building tonight
we first brought you the story yesterday
as joe moeller reports some of the
tenants moved thanks to a concerned
eight news now viewer who actually saw
the story
as of friday afternoon people were still
living upstairs and they were using a
ladder instead of the stairs you see
here to get down
now one woman said she knew she needed
to step in and help
and it's inconvenient for me my family
expected the kids this isn't exactly how
david goes and his family want to get to
their home
only here with the kids safety and
health the stairs are out by the street
because a car crashed into them
the crash happened sunday i'm willing to
help you with that many were surprised
by this story including 8 news now
viewer tracy from boulder city
we'll go ahead and take care of the
accommodations at the hotel california
and we'll go from there
she was shocked they were living like
this for several days so she moved the
family to a hotel for a few weeks i'm
appalled
i can't believe they have to crawl up
and down this ladder
somebody needs to help them out nobody
should have to have to deal this is a
dangerous situation
we reached out to the landlord again on
friday he got back to us saying they
were working on temporary housing
he also said they are going to repair
the stairs as fast as they can
tenants rights attorney don jensen told
us landlords are not legally required to
pay for substitute housing in situations
like this
tracy said she is willing to help the
family eventually move as well
i'm willing to help you with with the
deposits and with a couple months worth
of rent
the landlord also did tell me that they
were working to get temporary housing
for the other tenant who lives upstairs
the city says they were out here on
tuesday and they'll be back on march 8
to check on the repairs reporting in las
vegas joe mohler 8 news now